[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، أنا جاهز هنا ، نذهب إلى
ما أنت على وشك رؤيته وهو أمر رائع
تقريبًا لا يمكن تصوره حتى قبل 20 عامًا من
جراحة الدماغ ولكن لا يوجد مشرط ولا
شق ولا
موجات فوق صوتية مركزة على الدم هي أقوى صوت
لن تسمعه أبدًا ولكن  إنه صوت
يمكن أن ينقذ حياتك يومًا ما
أنفاس عميقة بطيئة لا تحبس أنفاسك جيدًا ،
فنحن في الواقع نصل إلى أعماق
الدماغ بالطاقة لإحداث
تأثير كبير للغاية نريد شيئًا
سيستمر
لبقية حياتها.  لقد كنت
جراح أعصاب منذ ما يقرب من ربع
قرن ولم أر هذا من قبل ، إنه
نوع من المدهش
[موسيقى]
بول يصب لي فنجان قهوتي الأول
كل صباح لأنه يمكنني تناول
فنجان كامل من القهوة إذا حمله إلى
المائدة  بالنسبة لي ، أشكركم على إحضار ذلك من
أجلي وسأخذه إذا حملته إلى
المنضدة ، فسأحصل على بقع من القهوة على
طول الطريق من إبريق القهوة إلى
الطاولة ولكن عليك التفكير في
كل ما تفعله
[الموسيقى]
تبدأ القصة ببريندا المبهجة البالغة من العمر
80 عامًا المليئة
بضحكة معدية ورغبة في القيام بالأشياء على
أكمل وجه ، حيث وجدت ذراعيها ببطء
ويديها تخونها ترتجف دون
تحذير من رعشة مألوفة
وهو أمر تم
نقله عبر الأجيال إلى عائلتي
من الملاحظ أن بريندا الأكبر من بين خمسة لديها
ثلاث أخوات يصبن أيضًا بنفس
الشيء ،
فالرعاش الأساسي هو حالة عادة ما تكون
تقدمية ببطء وتؤثر
بشكل أساسي على الأطراف ولكن أيضًا
الرأس وهي موجودة في حوالي 10
ملايين أمريكي
وفي  ما يقرب من واحد بالمائة على الأقل من
سكان العالم مع ارتفاع هذا العدد
إلى ما يقرب من خمسة بالمائة في من هم
فوق 65 عامًا. مع وجود عدد لا يحصى من المعاناة بما يكفي
لتحتاج إلى العلاج ، والآن هناك
حل ، كل ذلك دون الخوض في
السكين
[الموسيقى] في
الصباح الذي يزيد عن عقد من الزمان في
أخيرًا ، سأقوم بإعطاء
شعري فرشاة أخيرة وستختفي
[موسيقى] ارخي
كتفيك وتغمض عينيك ، يطلق عليه اسم
جراحة الأعصاب الوظيفية ، وهو
استهداف هياكل دقيقة في عمق
الدماغ لتغييرها لاستعادة
الوظيفة وفي  هذه الحالة لإيقاف
الرعاش
بالمعنى التبسيطي ، يمكنك أن تتخيل
أن هناك مجموعة من الخلايا العصبية غير الطبيعية
في هذا الهدف الواحد والتي تنطلق بعيدًا بشكل
لا يمكن السيطرة عليه مما يؤدي إلى العلاج
مما يؤدي إلى الاهتزاز الصحيح
لإنجاز أن الجراحين يستخدمون
لإجراء عمليات كبيرة أقطاب كهربائية في
اليد تحفيز بعض  مناطق من
الدماغ بحلول أواخر التسعينيات من القرن الماضي ، يمكن
فعل الشيء نفسه مع شيء يُعرف باسم
التحفيز العميق للدماغ
جراح الأعصاب جيف إلياس هو الرائد
في علاج الهزات الأساسية باستخدام
الموجات فوق الصوتية في عام 2011 ، حيث قاد
التجارب السريرية التي أثبتت
أهميتها للحصول على الموافقة التنظيمية
على  هذا الإجراء العلمي في
الولايات المتحدة
يربط إلياس بشكل أفضل الإجراء في
الدماغ باستئصال القلب حيث
تتعطل إيقاعات القلب غير الطبيعية عن طريق
حرق أو تجميد العضلات المستهدفة في
القلب
تمامًا مثل العدسة المكبرة التي يمكن أن
تحدد حزم الضوء في نقطة واحدة محددة
للحرق.  تعمل تقنية الموجات فوق الصوتية المركزة على الفتحة على إجبار حزم
الموجات الصوتية على
التقارب عند نقطة واحدة بمليمتر.
أن نوع
التطور الذي سنراه في
اعتقادك مع الموجات فوق الصوتية المركزة والأعمق
في التحفيز اليوم هو
المعيار الذهبي ، إنه علاج جيد جدًا ولكن
الموجات فوق الصوتية المركزة
ستحل
محل التحفيز العميق للدماغ ليس
لجميع المرضى ولكن
لجزء كبير من  السكان في رأيي
إذا عرضت على المرضى رمي عملة معدنية ،
فستخضع لعملية
جراحية لدماغك أو ستحصل على
شيء غير جائر يقول الناس لا حق
لا أريد أن أكون في هذا الجزء
لا تريد أن يضرب الشعر الدماغ ،
فأنت لا تريد أن يضرب الهواء الدماغ
الآن ، هل يمكنك لمس ذقنك ومد يدك
وكأنك تلمس شيئًا
أمامك ، شعرت بريندا بنفس الطريقة
واليوم ستفعل  أصبح واحدًا من
أكثر من 9000 مريض قاموا بهذا الإجراء في
جميع أنحاء العالم
مع أخت أخرى تنتظر بفارغ الصبر
النتائج.
التردد ستضع بريندا
رأسها هنا
مغمورة في سائل بدرجة حرارة 65 للحفاظ على برودة
رأسها ثم
يبدأ الإجراء
بالنسبة لك هو أن تبطئ
التنفس العميق من أجل الحفاظ على ثبات رأسها
أثناء العملية التي ستحتاجها بريندا
لتطبيق هذا الإطار ولا أرغب في
رؤية الإبر ، لذلك سأبقى
عيني مغلقة
بينما هذا غير جراحي
قد يكون من الصعب على البعض مشاهدة
الأدوية المخدرة ومن ثم هذه
البراغي المصنوعة من التيتانيوم لإغلاقها بالكامل  في المكان الذي قمت به بشكل
جيد ، لقد انتهيت تمامًا
[موسيقى]
الآن يبدأ إجراء ساعة ونصف الساعة
أولاً يأخذ الكمبيوتر مجموعة مختارة من
صور التصوير المقطعي المحوسب والتصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي لرسم خريطة لبنية
الدماغ والهدف المحدد
هناك  ثلاث لقطات اختبار ، تم فحص كل واحدة
بعد ذلك من
زاوية مختلفة مع التصوير الحراري ،
أريدك أن تبدأ في اللولب الأوسط
للخارج دون لمس الخط ، كل شيء على
ما يرام ، جرب أفضل ما لديك ،
حصلت على الماء ، دعنا نرى فقط بيز بالكامل
لست مضطرًا لذلك  اشربها ،
افعل فكرة عن المكان الذي توجد فيه ،
يمكننا بدء إجراء هنا ، لذلك
طُلب منها الرسم داخل هذه الحلزونات لرسم
خطوط قبل أي نوع من
العلاجات ، لذا سنرى ما سيحدث
أول لقطة علاجية رسمية تستغرق 11
ثانية
لذلك هذا هو  ربما يكون الوقت الأكثر أهمية
الآن لقد استعدنا للتو ،
إذا نجح الأمر ، فسنرى ، نعم ،
يجب أن يكون الأمر على ما يرام ،
فقد يستغرق الأمر بضع علاجات ، لكن
في بعض الأحيان سيفعله علاج واحد ، إنه
نوع مذهل
10 11 ثانية من الطاقة في  المكان المناسب في
الوقت المناسب من
المحتمل ، نعم ، يمكن حقًا أن
يغير حياتك
شيئًا آخر لمجرد رؤية الأيدي الكاملة ،
إنها الرقص
لقتل الخلايا في هذه البقعة المحددة ،
وزيادة الجرعة تعني زيادة
الطاقة الناتجة عن الموجات فوق الصوتية
لبريندا الأولى  تم ضبط جرعة العلاج
على 3000 جول مع
ضبط اللقطات التالية على 4500. لإعطائك بعض
السياق ، يمكن للطاقة من جوهرة واحدة أن
تضيء ضوء سلسلة عيد الميلاد واحد وات
لمدة ثانية
وبعد جرعتين أخريين ،
نعم أنت جيد
أخيرًا  الشيء الذي
أعتقد أنه يبدو جيدًا حقًا ، لذا في
العلاج الأخير الذي أجريناه ، لقد
انتهيت أخيرًا من النجاح ،
كيف تشعر يدك بأن يدي
تبدو جيدة ، هل يمكنك معرفة
الفرق من قبل نعم ،
إلى جانب الخطوط اللطيفة ، جرب هذا العلاج
[  موسيقى]
هذا مثير للإعجاب للغاية بالنسبة لساعة
ونصف الساعة ، لقد سررت أنا بشكل مضاعف أن
إجراء بريندا يستمر أقل من ساعتين
مع قضاء معظم الوقت في رسم الخرائط
واختبار الهدف ، ويتم ذلك
لأن مثل هذه العلاجات لا تخلو من
توازن المخاطر والاستقرار  يمكن أن
تتأثر على المدى الطويل إذا تم استهداف المنطقة الخاطئة
أو علاجها بشكل مفرط ، نعم
يبدو أنها تبدو جيدة حقًا إنها مكبوتة وهو
أمر يدركه الدكتور إلياس تمامًا
في جميع بريندا التي احتاجت إلى أربع
جرعات علاجية تبلغ 11 ثانية
تصل إلى أقل من دقيقة
اليوم تركز تكنولوجيا الموجات فوق الصوتية
منتشر عالميًا في مراحل مختلفة من
التجارب السريرية إلى الاستخدام التنظيمي المعتمد
مع العديد من التطبيقات التي لا تزال في
مراحلها الأولى
[موسيقى]
ماذا عن البلدان الأخرى حول
العالم هل هذا النوع من العلاج مثل ما
رأيناه لبريندا احتمالًا
واقعيًا في بلدان أخرى ، أوه بالتأكيد
في الولايات المتحدة ، هناك سبعة
مؤشرات سريرية حاصلة على
موافقة تنظيمية حول العالم تبلغ حوالي 35.
وفقًا لكاسيل ، كل شيء بدءًا
من الحد من الأورام السرطانية إلى
احتمال علاج الاكتئاب مطروح على
الطاولة
وعندما يتعلق الأمر بمعالجة الدماغ
عضوًا متخصصًا جدًا.
حماية محددة تعرف باسم حاجز الدم في الدماغ
يعتقد الدكتور كاسيل أن
الموجات فوق الصوتية المركزة يمكن أن تغير اللعبة التي
نظرت إليها في يدي وكانت هذه هي
المرة الأولى التي تمكنت فيها من رؤية
إصبعي ثابتًا منذ حوالي 20 عامًا
وأعتقد أنها بالتأكيد معجزة
وأنا  أشكر الرب على ذلك ،
تظل بريندا مبهجة وهي تسعى إلى
الكمال
ولكن الآن مع الأيدي لتتناسب مع
الطموح ومعرفة ما إذا كان من الأفضل ، نعم ،
إذا كنا سنجلس ونتحدث بعد 10
سنوات من الآن ، فهل سيصبح هذا
شيئًا
يفهمه الجميع  يعرف الموجات فوق الصوتية المركزة في
اعتقادي أنه في غضون 10 سنوات ،
ستكون الموجات فوق الصوتية المركزة علاجًا سائدًا يؤثر على
ملايين المرضى
كل عام في جميع أنحاء العالم ، لقد
حصلت على غرزة متقاطعة أفعلها
تقول إن Mighty Oak كان في يوم من الأيام
أكرون صغيرًا  أساسها
وهذا ما أفعله
الآن أنا أحمل غرام
[موسيقى]